in my humble opinion I do think that
there's a lot of value in the beginning
of your career really follow the
generalist approach see lots of
different things this is of course what
you will be able to do in many
Consulting roads where you start in a
generalist track and then in the first
one two three years have the opportunity
to see lots of different Industries lots
of different functions I think these are
two main benefits first of course by
exposing yourself to many of these
different areas probably this will help
you to make a more informed decision in
which area maybe at a later stage in
your career you really want to focus on
but then second after working in all
these different functions and industries
getting this broad experience what this
helps to build is confidence confidence
that you are able to navigate lots of
different environments that you are able
to add value in many many different
areas and instances of work